I believe that today we are ready to
do it already. We would like to have some things really
simply. But we cannot wait
months for this and we very much believe in success. I do not
know how much time we will need for this.
France
and any of our Western partners
need  to understand exactly what they are afraid of
losing and his constant
constant calls from this
Soviet fence that it is like nuclear
weapons all these are all the price of votes to a
weak person and how to act like this is a
driven beast He is afraid of losing his
life he must be afraid of the
power of the world he understands power if we
speak  about the isolation of the Russian
Federation among these people, it is necessary to do
it simply powerfully No blah blah blah, but
isolation or
visa is very serious, you just have to choose a side,
neither Ukraine nor Russia, no, choose your values
and be with that side, with that state,
what values  autocratic values ​​may be closer to you, for some people,
please
choose Russia then, but if you say
that you are a democratic state that sees
itself in the European Union, in NATO, well, don't lie,
just don't lie, be on the side of these
values,
and you already want to end the war, but
sooner  well, this is not related to the
administration will be the same or it will
change President Biden, he is the
president of a time-scale war and he
helped us more than the president when
Trump was
and if we are talking about the administration, but
at the same time We must understand that then it
was not  full-scale war And I don't know
how Trump would act I didn't understand why
[music]
and Donald Trump said that I
would have put Putin and Zelensky in two
presidents for 24 hours and would have ended the war
Well he could have done it then when he was well
not that  this is
how it happened, the issue was probably not so acute
then, because there was no full-scale
invasion, if you analyze
But nevertheless, our territories were occupied,
and in such a situation, when there is
support, you are afraid of change, and I will tell you
frankly, when you say a change of
administration, how do I feel about it?
any person,
you want to change for the better, the better side,
but it can be different
... a
weapon capable of stopping some types of
missiles of the Russian Federation, which it
uses on our civilian population,
schools, infrastructure, energy
systems, the only system in the world - this is
Petriv, this war taught him  people, it's time and that's
all, and here's my answer: there is a weapon that
simply disables Russia's ability to
intimidate tens of millions of people,
Petrius is a reality. It will be the next offensive.
education Without
control in the sky is very dangerous
Imagine the feeling of a military man who knows
I don't have a roof
and he doesn't understand why neighboring countries
have it if everyone knows that we need
protection from the sky, what's the problem with modern
planes,
what's the issue of
tracking
I believe that  some NATO countries are so
afraid of Russia that they are not ready to see
Ukraine in the Union if they don't see us and don't
give us some kind of signal Vilnius
I think Ukraine has nothing to do on this
site We don't want to be in NATO during the
war it
should have been too late for these 15 years
should have been before we understand that
we will not be in NATO or in any
powerful security union
during this war, but tell me
how many lives is worth one phrase at the
Vilnius summit how many lives of
Ukrainians is worth the phrase Ukraine will be in
NATO After this war after  it will be
safe
only it costs
I I don't know
I honestly tell you I don't know
the driver is a
matter of desire And I would like them to
be involved in the peace formula Like the
United States like the European Union like India
representatives of
Latin America Asia etc. it
doesn't matter what you have between you in  economy
in energy,
etc.;
the inspector
[music]
is engaged in speec
such heroic people die because of this war
at least even if there are some
moments like I said they should be
when you are alone and alone with
yourself
I like to read
different literature absolutely I like to
read like this 3-4 books at the same time to
relax  with my family and this is very
cool
but I use it very correctly
[laughter]
very Smart
English
English better
Show
teacher for my soundme
how did I tell you time is people
it is everywhere and on the battlefield and in life in  to
any